take out services like doordash and
postmates we'll have some new
competition next month restaurant owners
in and around las vegas coming together
to launch their own food service
delivery platform 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond joins us live in the
newsroom with more on the new initiative
hi kristen brian they're challenging big
app-based platforms because of
growing frustrations over fees during
the pandemic and
they plan to have it ready in april
we're nervous
but i think the timing is right valley
restaurants take action
it's a local issue that is going to be
sold locally roughly a hundred places
including tuckotarian co-owned by carlos
carroll
form a local cooperative called loco las
vegas
a franchise ready to compete with big
tech app-based delivery services
it's meant to be operated by restaurants
and owned by restaurants
a task spearheaded by his wife kristen
carroll
also a co-owner of tacoterion
we'll start going live in chunks so
we'll start in the southwest
and then we'll just keep building and
building and building and building until
we eventually cover the entire valley
carol tells me various reasons motivated
this initiative
including third-party companies charging
as much as 30 percent per food
ordered local las vegas plans to cap
commissions at 15 percent
with a goal of lowering it even more
over time any restaurant in las vegas
can use the co-op
and just pay the flat 15 percent and
that's it but some restaurant owners
like jim reese of hash house of gogo
remain hesitant to join as a shareholder
he questions the marketing plan and
convincing people to use the new app
we just need to see whether they'll be
able to generate enough
business to make it you know really make
sense
in a city the size of las vegas and
if it does i think we'll be very
interested generating a buzz
while introducing a new way for
customers to order their favorite foods
the money is going to stay in las vegas
not in silicon valley
local las vegas plans to have drivers
and they'll be required to carry a
food delivery card as well as complete
training kristin tells me they'll be
paid based on commission
and tips which may average about 15
dollars an hour
also the goal is to have them deliver
food immediately so
orders are not waiting on restaurant
counters again
expect this app available starting late
april reporting live in the newsroom i'm
kristen drummond 8 news now